all the patients data are on an iPad the
files are digital at the Lucas clinic
doctors can access any relevant
information at the touch of a finger as
you can assign disease i must say that
it helps a lot because it makes our life
easier i get the results directly on my
ipad so everything is faster he does in
fuchsia nila if everything is working if
anything goes wrong in the system but
digital hospital can quickly come to a
standstill that's what happened in
February the clinic had to go back to
using old-fashioned methods like paper
and pens and the telephone the virus had
infected the IT system a Tesla [ __ ]
Trojan where nicknamed lucky the cyber
attack is still under investigation some
500 kilometers away in English that
kaspersky lab employees are very aware
of the problem the company sells
antivirus software all over the world
the R&D department is becoming more and
more familiar with Tesla crypt invented
also free of the National Comte it's
exactly here when this mall where gets
into a computer it encrypts all the data
the user gets a message saying that it's
still there but can't be accessed unless
a certain amount of money is paid okay
no sorry Betty and renegade patacas I'll
admit movida hun lofty doesn't become
anyone can be the victim of a cyber
attack even whole cities such as
Dettelbach in bavaria it was recently
targeted to the bemusement of the locals
the year's top of idol bites the city
council was closed for a few days the
mayor wasn't available for some reason I
think we can go in moon others were
particularly annoyed by the fact that
there were no security backups this
meant that the council was blackmailed
and chose to pay the ransom to regain
access to the encrypted data
they should have brought in specialists
instead of paying the ransom calling
doesn t more four of eight everyone got
away with it we'd be a banana republic
dig ahead and Sons flicked me a shot
there might have been more harm done
otherwise I think it was right that's
what many victims of cyber attacks think
they keep quiet and pay to the dismay of
the bullies becomes clarakuoch after
police I've our clear message is that
nobody should pay a ransom to
blackmailers nothing comes on in the
ground isn't it this encourages them to
start again and just increases their
greed and we really want to avoid that a
price on this one the orbiting from
heightened cyber crime is on the up
every day Kaspersky Lab researchers find
some 325,000 harmful programs that the
Italian turkelton is an enemy the
digital underground there's an economic
sector of its own there are certain
services their people sell malware that
is already configured or with a list of
options like when you buy a car yet the
config oh here what I'm done off press
list if you're an ultra bar advisor the
Lucas clinic reacted as it should have
they shut down all the computers
resorted to the backups and made no
payment employees will receive further
training on how to deal with such
attacks in the future Conrad easy hide
we can only improve security we are much
more vulnerable than before in terms of
what happens if our IT systems stopped
working but think about cars that are
not driven by people that's something
people want but imagine what might
happen if they stop working in one of
our lives in new Venice news from suny
request on Posse our culture for now the
system is working again and no data went
missing the doctors are doing their
rounds as usual with all the information
they need on their iPads